je vends des charges sociales pour
l'industrie textile les 39 heures pas un
travailleur ne doit craindre pour son
pouvoir d'achat
déclare le chef de l'état madrid le
dialogue est-ouest suspendu l'éboulement
de la mine de la houle après la mort de
deux mineurs les syndicats mettent en
cause les conditions de sécurité
madame monsieur bonsoir à prime abord la
sphère al'allure d'une caricature de
notre génie national un commando pour
libérer 750000 camembert en fait ce qui
s'est passé à isigny dans le calvados
lundi dernier prend la dimension d'une
affaire judiciaire et politique
c'est 200 hommes dont beaucoup d'anciens
part à organiser en commando par le
patron d'une société de gardiennage pour
aider son ami directeur de la laiterie
la minutie de l'opération le fait que le
maire et la gendarmerie étaient en fait
prévenu du coup de force auquel ils ont
en partie assisté l'indignation des
syndicats devant ce coup de force
pratiquement sans précédent
tous ces éléments font en tout cas de la
sphère d'isigny une affaire nationale
cet après midi le responsable du
commando s'est présenté spontanément
chez le juge d'instruction à caen daniel
leconte isigny est encore sous le choc
après l'opération de commando organisé
par le patron de la fromagerie baigner
entre ces travailleurs en grève
37 anciens parachutistes aidés par des
employés du groupe on s'en souvient
était venu dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi
récupérez 750 mille fromages
toute la nuit qu'ils avaient pu
impunément terroriser les grévistes
la première parole qui a été dit ça il
ya eu un coup de sifflet donné s'était
donné onze charges on attaque on charge
voilà alors aussi retourné moi j'étais à
la barre y est jeune et de laisser une
camarade parti me suis retourné j'avais
un gros bruit devant moi il m'a dit que
tu as allonge toi j'ai dit non non j'ai
pas de monthois saloperie je lui ai dit
ah ben je n'ai pas coup dans le dos puis
la bombe en veux tu en voilà
et puis ils ont couru les camarades dans
la coupe
on veut bien tu pourrais les gens
étaient terminées chez vous chopez d'un
moment ils ont dit comme ça aide
deux par deux dans les frigos et d'aller
nous séparer les femmes et les hommes
sinon ils ont fait prouvant le contraire
mais c'est bien normal chez bolliger
alerter immédiatement accompagné des
saints gendarmes locaux le maire
d'eysines inhalé un jeu que je constate
et organisé j'ai entendu prononcer par
le responsable de l'opération les mots
1er 2e groupe équipes etc
j'ai vu des gens avec des brassards de
couleurs différentes selon leur l'euro
ou leurs responsabilités j'ai assisté au
départ par exemple
ça s'est fait dans un ordre parfait
militairement organisée c'est en ayant
que protection devant et derrière les
camions qui emmenait les camemberts
renforts importants à la sortie pendant
le départ des véhicules constitution
d'une arrière-garde qui a un signal
donné est montée aux vols dans les
voitures qui partait de façon que les
derniers par touches en même temps
c'était quelque chose de parfaitement
tordu accusés qui était penché de longue
date
vous avez dit que vous aviez appelé le
sous préfet le plus fait pour demander
des renforts qu'est ce qui vous a été
répondu que ça n'était pas possible à
cause du fait que ces gens qui étaient
intervenus dans l'établissement étaient
chez eux et qui n'était pas possible la
force publique d'intervenir je suis
grand domaine privé vous avez accepté
cet argument je n'ai pris comme tel dire
que je dois accepter dans le moment non
parce que j'avais comme souci les trente
et une personnes qui étaient prises
comme otages et je dis bien otage parce
que ces gens là se sont entendu dire par
plusieurs comme si ceux qui sont dehors
bouge c'est vous qui trinquent et
c'était donc vers des otages devrons
nous sommes fernand loustau l'ancien
para qui dirigeait le commando est
encore entendu par le juge d'instruction
à quand le président du groupe
communiste à l'assemblée nationale andré
lajoinie a posé une question écrite au
ministre de l'intérieur en demandant que
toute la lumière soit faite je cite sur
les conditions dans lesquelles ce coup
de force de caractère fasciste a pu
avoir lieu
de son côté le bureau exécutif du parti
socialiste demande au gouvernement qu'il
agisse avec fermeté pour le strict
respect de la légalité républicaine
et il appelle les forces politiques de
gauche les organisations syndicales à
manifester ensemble sur place leur
solidarité avec les travailleurs agressé
conseil des ministres aujourd'hui pas un
travailleur ne doit craindre pour son
pouvoir d'achat à la suite de
l'application des 39 heures
ce propos du chef de l'état montre bien
après les déclarations du premier
ministre et du ministre du travail dans
quel sens va s'engager demain à matignon
le tour de table patronat-syndicats sur
la réduction du temps de travail
la majeure partie de notre journal
demain soir sera consacré à ce dossier
revenons au conseil des ministres le
président de la république a demandé au
gouvernement d'étudier
mise en place d'un livret d'épargné
populaire indexées sur l'inflation est
exonérée d'impôt pour les français les
plus défavorisés
mais c'est l'industrie textile qui a
fait l'objet de la décision la plus
attendue du gouvernement pour enrayer la
crise dans ce secteur une partie des
cotisations sociales des entreprises
seront prises à charge par l'état sous
réserve que les entreprises textiles
s'engage à investir et augmenter le
nombre d'emplois elles bénéficieront
pendant deux ans d'une réduction
maximale de douze points de leurs
charges sociales
le but sauver 20000 emplois en un an
dans ce secteur où la concurrence
étrangère et fatale laurent schwarz et
jacques boulard ont découvert un patron
qui décide de fabriquer français est une
entreprise qui rouvre ses portes
leur enquête cet homme s'appelle benoît
bartherotte c'est le patron de la maison
de couture jacques esterel et comme tous
les grands couturiers
il créé sur mesure des modèles qu'il
vend à des gens fortunés
pourtant ce n'est pas comme cela que les
grands couturiers gagne de l'argent il
en gagne de l'argent en vendant leurs
griffes à des fabricants de hong kong de
corée ou même d'italie et c'est
justement cette pratique que le patron
de jacques esterel a décidé d'abandonner
il veut désormais fabriqués en france
seulement voilà en dehors de son petit
atelier de couture benoît bartherotte
n'a jusqu'à présent aucun moyen de
production
or au même moment dans une petite vallée
des vosges une usine de filature et de
tissage qui employait plus de 240
personnes étaient arrêtées depuis près
d'un an
son patron avait mis la clé sous la
porte et les ouvriers occupent l usine
mise au courant de la situation benoît
bartherotte décidé de reprendre cette
usine et avec l'aide de la cgt de
réembaucher progressivement le personnel
travaille ma foi ici j'en suis inouïe
maintenant j'espère avoir ma retraite
proportionnelle à 55 ans d'abord fouet
donc est ce que vous voulez moi j'ai mon
fils qui travaillait bien moi je
prendrais le fonds de solidarité et puis
je laisserai la place à maurice musicaux
avant filature filature donc de la
filature la confection ça vous fait pas
peur de changer de métier ont pas
tellement non
ça il faut faire travailler comme un
genre que cela ou dans une autre usine y
ait ce qui est bon pour les usines dans
la région
oui on aime une embauche prendre
entretenue par les ouvriers qui ont
occupé lusine des machines reprenne vie
et avec la collaboration de la cgt les
ré embauche se succèdent à un rythme
cadencé
est ce que ça nous fait pas drôle de
devenir de faire partie de la direction
d'une usine
oui oui ça va oui bien sûr ça m'a un peu
choqué au départ ma femme je pense
pouvoir gérer ça très bien étant donné
que je connais toutes les personnes de
l'entreprise et que bon je pense y fera
pas de problème à ce niveau là malgré
l'âge les machines qu'il a trouvé ici
benoît bartherotte n'a pas peur de la
concurrence étrangère il est évident
qu'on n'aura jamais les mêmes les mêmes
rendements sur le plan quantitatif condé
coréen
et même si nous essayons de faire la
compétition avec eux c'est à dire
d'acheter des machines ultramodernes qui
ça veut dire papa et maman
eh bien on sera toujours pas compétitifs
parce que derrière ses machines il y à
des coréens et qu'ici il ya des français
donc on ne sera toujours pas compétitif
je crois que c'est pas sur ce plan là
que ça se passe
je crois que c'est plutôt sur le plan de
la qualité nous avons une une culture
textile nous avons nous avons une
impasse et et nous savons faire un
certain nombre de choses qui ne savent
pas faire
on nous comptons reprendre des unités de
production et faire un seul modèle alors
n'oublieront pas une année le le revers
est large le revers et et 3 l'année
suivante parce que c'est la mode et
c'est un nom un revers c'est d'abord un
endroit c'est à dire ça fonctionne et
dans le littré français le dictionnaire
français le tailleur c'est celui qui
relève ce qui n'est pas nécessaire alors
c'est ce que nous ferons et nous ferons
qu'un modèle mais par contre nous le
vendrons dans le monde entier
voilà dès maintenant
le patron de jacques esterel envisage de
racheter une deuxième usine mavs est un
exemple encourageant que beaucoup de
députés confrontés sur le terrain de
leur circonscription à la réalité
économique et sociale voudrait sans
doute voir suivi en effet loin du palais
bourbon et de sa rhétorique les nouveaux
élus découvrent
et difficultés et parfois les
contradictions des problèmes qu'il faut
résoudre
c'est le cas de jacques bas des 38 ans
député maire de saint chamond
professeur d'université de son état ils
passent en moyenne trois jours à paris
quatre jours dans sa circonscription ce
sont les rudes délices de la vie
parlementaire
son expérience son portrait patricia
charnelet et alain pagano saint chamond
42 mille habitants une ville
industrielle à 95% ce département de la
loire est le plus touché de la région
rhône alpes près de 10 et demi pour cent
de la population active au chômage
la moyenne nationale est de 8%
la raison est simple cette vallée subi
les conséquences de la double crise du
textile et de la sidérurgie
les entreprises n'ont pas su ou pas pu
se reconvertir à temps et la situation
va plutôt en steak ratant ce jour là les
syndicats d'une usine de cylindres de
laminoir racheté par usinor sont venus
chez le député pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
quatorze suppressions de postes ont été
annoncées des départs en préretraite
sans aucune perspective d'embauché de
l'analyse que voulait faire des termes
de bénéfices et autres précisent qu'ils
pourraient s'appliquer a repris
s'aperçoit qu'il ya peu près 30% des
cylindres qui viennent de l'étranger est
en notamment d'allemagne
donc déjà ce production l'a rapatrié en
france quand on sait que seule mère
seule mère achète une bonne partie de
ses cylindres étrangers donc il déjà eu
les gestes solution aussi la réduction
du temps de travail qui en qui
apporterait déjà selon les syndicats la
direction refuse toute discussion sur le
temps de travail tant qu'un accord n'a
pas été conclu pour l'ensemble du groupe
le député lui a promis d'intervenir
auprès du ministère de l'industrie et du
pdg d'usinor
est-ce que c'est plus facile depuis que
vous êtes un député socialiste oui les
rapports sont semble plus facile par le
fait que je lis ça ils écoutent
davantage les travailleurs et puis ça
reste pas dans un vase clos oui il prend
en compte le problème ça aboutit
concrètement le rôle du député ne se
limite pourtant pas d intervention
jacques bas des affaires acheté par la
municipalité ces locaux industriels
il a réussi à faire repartir une
fabrique de peluche dont tout le
personnel avait été licencié ce qui
n'empêche pas les patrons de
l'entreprise pourtant aidé par la ville
de se plaindre de l'augmentation des
charges sociales et des problèmes de
trésorerie
quels sont les objectifs d'une
entreprise comme la vôtre
faire de l'emploi et des profits ses
deux sauts sont dissociables est
actuellement à ce que vous pouvez faire
du profit et appliquer les lois sociales
dans une entreprise qui démarre c'est
faut choisir où l'un ou l'autre
malheureusement sur difficile c'est
difficile
pourquoi bien disons que une entreprise
qui démarre à faire une conquête du
marché dans un marché qui est même
difficile où l'épaisseur batailler dans
le fond on nous attend pas le député
pense que les lois sociales faciliteront
la reconquête du marché intérieur
il est donc déterminé à tout faire pour
ne pas subir les problèmes économiques
la vie quotidienne nous oblige à être
réaliste faut savoir que l'on ne
s'attaque aux réalités que l'on ne
s'attaque à un héritage qu en respectant
un certain nombre de règles et que le
corps social comme le corps économique
n'est pas quelque chose qui se modifie
forcément au bulldozer au bazooka
l'exercice du pouvoir surtout en période
difficile conduit au pragmatisme
mais au delà du discours réaliste il
faut également comprendre désir de
changement et volonté de réussir
politique avec une petite phrase de
roger chinaud l'ancien président du
groupe udf à l'assemblée nationale
parlait à france inter de valéry giscard
d'estaing
il doit revenir sur la scène politique
dit roger chinaud c'est le seul homme
qui ait fait passer l'intérêt de son
pays avant le sien et la satisfaction de
son ambition propres monsieur chinaud
s'est cependant défendu de vouloir
attiser une guerre des chefs au sein de
l'opposition l'étranger maintenant des
troubles graves ont éclaté aujourd'hui
en syrie dans la ville de hama à 200 km
de damas
c'est ce qu'affirme le département
d'état américain de violents combats
entre les forces gouvernementales et les
opposants au régime se poursuivraient en
ce moment même en pologne la
normalisation continue avec son train de
procéder sentence souvent lourdes
le numéro 2 de solidarité miroslav
krupinski qui avait échappé aux premiers
rafle a été arrêté et sera déféré devant
un tribunal militaire
le directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire a révélé aujourd'hui qu'il
y avait dans le pays
24 camps d'internement pour la première
fois depuis le coup de force les
journalistes étrangers ont pu se rendre
à gdansk le berceau de solidarité
patricia cost que dans ce cas la ville
symbole où tout a commencé avec son
monument aux ouvriers morts érigé par
solidarité dans un car une vingtaine de
journalistes étrangers invités pour la
première fois dans cette ville
brûlot c'est un voyage très très
organisée et encadrée
le caméraman un américain prend au vol
quelques images ici un graffiti qui
tentera parait-il de couvrir tous les
murs de la pologne
l'hiver est à venir le printemps à nous
les graffitis les miliciens les recouvre
sa ble ment de peinture jaune sinon tout
est calme lice la sortie les fameux
chantiers lénine ressemble à toutes les
sorties des usines du monde en face sur
le monument en mémoire des émeutes de
1970 les autorités ont même fait passer
les noms des victimes de la répression
reste des fleurs et de pierres la statue
de l'ouvrier maintenant inconnue la
pologne reste le test sinon le calvaire
de la détente ou de ce qu'il en reste
la conférence de madrid vous le savez a
été interrompu hier le président
polonais de la séance
jugeant que les réquisitoires
occidentaux contre moscou et varsovie
passé les bornes
le secrétaire d'état américain alexander
haig a déclaré aujourd'hui que les pays
de l'est avait fait je cite une erreur
de jugement malheureuse vis-à-vis des
neutres et des non-alignés en bloquant
ainsi la conférence
cela démontre at il dit la faiblesse et
la compatibilité de la politique de
moscou au regard des droits de l'homme
et monsieur etc s'est félicité de
l'unité démontrer à madrid par les pays
occidentaux
faut bien le dire le blocage de la
conférence arrange plutôt les affaires
des deux grands pôles now oui absolument
la manoeuvre tenté il faut bien le dire
réussi hier lire après midi à madrid par
les polonais a eu comme conséquence
immédiate de ressouder si vous voulez le
bloc occidental et de la même occasion
ressouder les liens entre les différents
pays de l'est de sorte qu'aujourd'hui on
assiste et ce pour la première fois je
crois depuis très longtemps une
confrontation entre deux blocs avec en
plus comme au pire moment de la guerre
froide
l'interruption brutale du dialogue entre
l'est et l'ouest
on va pourtant rediscuter vendredi à
madrid mais pendant quelques heures
seulement car il semble bien qu'on
s'achemine déjà vers un ajournement de
cette conférence sur la sécurité avec un
point d'interrogation majeur les
soviétiques ont-ils vraiment décidé de
couper tous les ponts de tous les forums
de discussion entre l'est et l'ouest
donc aux répondants de jeu
vendredi matin sans doute à madrid en
tout cas ce sont les européens et
surtout les allemands qui sont plutôt
embarrassé oui si vous voulez dans cette
affaire la position des européens
étaient ces nouvelles c'est en effet la
première fois aussi depuis très
longtemps qu'ils se trouvent tous aussi
clairement et aussi nettement engagé
avec les états unis sur cette affaire
polonaise les européens sont tout à fait
satisfait également de voir les
américains prendre une position ferme
cependant les états unis sont bien
décidés à aller jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire de maintenir et même
accentué leur pression leurs sanctions
économiques contre l'union soviétique et
c'est justement sur ce thème que ces
mêmes européens ne veulent pas franchir
c'est un pas qui ne veulent pas franchir
2 tu es sont donc en train de
s'affronter en ce moment celle des
américains qui ont semblent type choisi
la confrontation jusqu'au bout et c'est
les européens qui est-il que sanctionner
les pays de l'est aboutir et en ce
moment un résultat inverse de celui
escompté à savoir provoquer à l'est le
réflexe de la citadelle assiégée
démission fracassante aux nations unies
le directeur de la division des droits
de l'homme à hollandais claque la porte
mettant en cause les moyens dérisoires
dont il dispose et les pressions dont il
est l'objet
c'est la crédibilité des nations unies
qui est en cause dit il
prod'homme toujours bafoués en turquie
un journaliste vient d'être condamné à
27 ans de prison pour avoir porté
atteinte aux sentiments nationaux selon
le tribunal militaire d'ankara et
diffuser de la propagande communiste et
kurdes en france l'éboulement survenu au
puits de la houve en moselle a fait
finalement deux morts les deux mineurs
bloqués hier soir n'ont pu être dégagée
depuis le début de l'année c'est le
quatrième accident qui endeuille les
houillères de lorraine mettant en cause
les conditions d'hygiène et de sécurité
les syndicats appellent à la grève
vendredi prochain dominique tierces
le puits de la houve en lorraine symbole
de la relance charbonnières dans la
région mais aussi désormais symbole
d'accident les mineurs qui font remonter
cette nuit après l'éboulement sont
encore sous le choc
ça s'est passé très très vite
une de seconde
la secousse est venu c'est tout quoi
c'est fermé
et comment vous avez réussi à vous
soumettre les sauveteurs sont venus
n'ont sorti que vous êtes rendu compte
que deux de vos camarades étaient
prisonniers
non je ne suis pas vraiment rendu compte
on a quand même pensé qu'ils ont pu
sauver coadout côtés
ce n'est pas en quoi du tout il manque
deux clés de plus ce soir sur le grand
tableau de la salle des préparatifs de
clés de lampes de compagnons 27 et 18
ans ce qui allonge la liste puisque la
semaine dernière dans le même puis un
autre mineur a trouvé la mort lourd
bilan depuis le début de l'année quatre
accidents inexplicable puisque la
direction dit s'efforçaient d'appliquer
des consignes de sécurité très strict
cet accident se produit dans une galerie
soutenue avec des cintres métalliques de
haute de grand poids utilisé dans des
centaines et centaines de guides de
galeries en europe il se produit à la
houve entre deux points peut-être plus
vulnérables que sur le front de taille
la carrure que nous faisions de dépasser
alors nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi le
soutènement a cédé à 7 ans le comprendre
aucune explication rationnelle mais les
syndicats refusent la fatalité il accuse
production toujours production sans
assez de précautions vous disant que les
vrais responsables se situe au niveau de
ceux de ceux qui doivent nous faire de
la formation
d'encre alors on constate aussi
actuellement que dans les jeunes mineurs
qui sont à l'écart des écoles ils sont
donc vous et ils sont donc sacrifié à la
production dès leur jeune âge et nous on
dit qu on se posait qu'il sorte qu'est
ce qui se passe actuellement aussi dans
les chaudières production car le puits
de la houve peut s'enorgueillir de bons
résultats six mille kilos de houille
extrait par jour et par rome mais la
série d'accidents n'incite pas les 13
cents mineurs du puy à se réjouir de ce
score moins 0,9 pour cent c'est le
chiffre du jour il illustre la légère
amélioration de la sécurité routière en
france le nombre des tués de la route a
diminué de 0,9 pour cent quatre-vingts
par rapport à l'année précédente d'après
le comité interministériel de la
sécurité routière
l'amélioration concerne plus les piétons
et les utilisateurs de deux roues que
les automobilistes
en tout cas il ya eu moins d'accidents
mortels en 80 quand 65 alors que le parc
automobile a doublé mais la france reste
avec le portugal et l'autriche l'un des
pays européens les plus enclins aux
accidents de la route
laissez-nous veulent et c'est le titre
d'un nouveau tube au hit parade
britannique enregistré par des hôtesses
de l'éclair airways qui entendent ainsi
contribuer au sauvetage de la compagnie
aérienne sur freddy a vendu aujourd'hui
deux filiales de son groupe mais la
compagnie aérienne n'a pas trouvé
preneur
le champion des vols à bon marché se dit
prêt à créer avec son personnel une
compagnie aérienne populaire en tout cas
les usagers protestent
si à new york les voyageurs bloqués ont
manifesté aujourd'hui leur
mécontentement et leur solidarité
tandis qu'à paris c'est créer une
association française des amis de fredy
les coeurs pourtant la compagnie
n'opérait pas en france qui n'est pas le
paradis des entreprises de ce genre
danielle cattelin aéroport d'orly
cet avion rouge et blanc de la compagnie
de charters minerve décollera samedi à
8h30
mais il décollera à vide pour bruxelles
où il prendra à son bord des passagers
venus eux aussi de paris mais par la
route en autobus alors seulement tout le
monde quand volera vers pointe à pitre
destination finale de l'avion
les charters que nous affrétons à
destination de pointe-à-pitre
depuis le samedi 6 février d'école de
bruxelles
car lorsque la compagnie de charters
minerve compagnie française a mené ce
qu'on appelle les droites afrique c'est
à dire l'autorisation à la fin de
décoller et de se poser après des
discussions avec le ministère des
transports n'a pas obtenu l'autorisation
de décoller de paris mais uniquement de
bruxelles et de bâle mulhouse
la raison principale est de ne pas
porter atteinte au monopole de la
compagnie nationale air france
le ministre de transports dans le cas
précis protège elle la compagnie air
france air france à des rappeurs
extrêmement étroits avec le ministère
des transports et il n'est pas normal
qu'il y ait sur les antilles comme ça
beaucoup de destinations une position de
monopole
first air france assume une mission de
service public
nous ne contestons pas cette dimension
du service public mais à notre avis il
n'y a pas concurrence entre les
compagnies régulières et et compagnies
de charters nelia doublement parité pour
le moment ni le ministère des transports
ni la compagnie air france ne jugent
utile de faire des commentaires sur
cette prise de position qui les met en
cause un nouveau président pour la
cinémathèque française c'est le metteur
en scène costa gavras qui succède à
l'ancien ministre de la culture michel
guy costa gavras est un cinéaste engagé
qui avait rendu justice à ses origines
grecques et au colonel dans son fameux
film z un résultat de football
maintenant sochaux et strasbourg ont
fait match nul aujourd'hui de but
partout en match en retard du
championnat de france de première
division
il y aura un kart et demain à vincennes
dans le prix châteaurenard les
pronostics de pirey bresse ou s'inscrire
ce retrait quand les voilà le 2e 1 le 8
le 6 le dise
le 14 le 7 et le 12 pronostic ou
prévisions le temps laurent baumel et
bien christine toujours de la douceur
toujours du soleil mais tout de même un
soleil voilé en effet le baromètre
légèrement à la baisse et quelques
nuages vont pénétrer sur l'ouest du pays
aurait tout de suite allé voir la carte
pour donc demain jeudi on s'aperçoit
qu'il y aura d'abord du brouillard dans
certaines vallées des rivières le matin
et un peu partout un ciel un petit peu
gris tout à faut lever du jour ensuite
de belles éclaircies avec tout de même
un soleil parfois voilé dans l'ouest et
le nord du pays des nuages très haut
dans le ciel et puis des régions où il
ya un peu plus de nuages tout de même
d'une part d'une côté de la méditerranée
des régions méridionales en effet des
nuages reviennent remonte depuis le
sahara dans ces régions mais pas de
pluie en perspective en range des
petites pluies faibles de la bretagne à
la flandre avec ces nuages qui frôlent
et qui arrose en fait surtout les îles
britanniques et qui progressons un petit
peu dans l'intérieur dans la journée
donc de demain les températures fraîches
très fraîches le matin tout de même avec
l'anticyclone puisqu'il y aura des
gelées locales veille en particulier
dans le nord-est dans le centre et
peut-être même dans le sud ouest avec
donc jusqu'à -2 ou moins trois parfois
guère moins tout de même puis l'après
midi les températures toujours douces
avec quelques records sans doute encore
comme aujourd'hui à 16 17 ou 18 degrés
dans le sud ouest du pays enfin pour
terminer l'agenda et pendant que vous
consultez là je vous dirais que vendredi
un peu plus de nuages tout de même mais
les nuages qui ne donneront pas beaucoup
plus alors ma foi tout va bien et la
douceur continue gagné journal à 23h15
avec hervé claude demey midi philippe
labro recevra à la fièvre du samedi soir
john travolta héros d'un nouveau film je
vous rappelle les titres de cette
édition conseil des ministres allègement
des charges sociales pour l'industrie
textile demain à matignon le point sur
la réduction du temps de travail
madrid le dialogue est-ouest suspendu
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal avant de
vous quitter je vous rappelle
l'opération spéciale japon que la
rédaction d'antenne 2 en collaboration
avec la télévision japonaise nhk valence
et du 10 au 14 avril prochain gérard ce
badge rappelle l'écran
nous vous proposons de participer
directement à cette opération de deux
façons premièrement si à titre personnel
un sujet précis celui-ci de votre
intérêt écrivez nous si votre reportage
est réalisable
il sera diffusé deuxièmement si vous
habitez un village si vous êtes membre
d'une collectivité d'un comité
d'entreprise d'une usine dont le devenir
est directement liée au destin japonais
écrivez nous nous organiserons un direct
entre vous et des interlocuteurs
japonais choisi par vous et qui
répondront à vos questions vous avez
jusqu'à la fin de cette semaine pour
nous écrire à cette adresse
le japon et vous antenne 2 pièces 699
case rue cognacq-jay 75007 paris
maintenant bonne soirée sur antenne 2 je
vous retrouverai demain à 20 heures